gilmore lit up wembley last week he was
man of the match on his first
international start
his second will have to wait a positive
covet test has sidelined him in
self-isolation
for 10 days he'll miss scotland's final
group game against croatia
no close contacts have been identified
in the camp so for now
he sits out alone his coach gave
confirmation
if not further details obviously a blow
for is in
in terms of the team but a chance for
someone else
i'm sure there'll be a relief that there
was no other close contacts how
confident were you that that was going
to be the result when you found out
about
billy's positive case that's it's not my
department my department's getting the
team ready for
an absolutely massive game tomorrow
against croatia and that's
that's what i've been concentrating on
the scotland midfielder's positive test
was
negative news for england too billy
gilmore's chelsea teammates mason
mountain ben chilwell
was seen hugging him at full time on
friday they've been asked to
self-isolate
for now despite negative tests
there's obviously got to be quite a
doubt
but there's still a lot of discussions
and investigations going on behind the
scenes
so um the they're at the moment
as andy just said they're isolating um
and we just have to find out over the
next sort of 12 hours or so
in terms of um of the
covid regulations where
i think every team is trying to apply
those as
vigorously as they can public health
england say they set the protocols and
guidance
surrounding the wembley game a football
match itself
is not considered close contact although
at least some members of the scientific
community
do regard it as a risk it seems very
unlikely to me
that a sort of uh fleeting passing
interaction between people would have
qualified them as having potentially
been exposed to somebody who's been
infected
it's not the first time covet has hit
team preparations at this tournament
there's every chance it won't be the
last it is
the matter of life and death prioritized
over football
as it's more important than that james
matthews sky news
glasgow